It looks kind of organic doesn't it? Hey
what's up guys I hope you're feeling
hungry today because in this video we're
making pancakes
degasified pancakes. Now over the last
couple of months I've literally seen
hundreds and hundreds of requests of
people asking me to take pancake mix and
put it in the vacuum chamber.
What kind of pancakes would you make if
you sucked all the air bubbles out of
them? So I randomly pulled out a comment
from Remiel Kasim who said, Grant you
have to make a pancake batter then take
out all the bubbles then cook it it
should turn out to be really [ satisfying ]
well Remiel that's what we're putting to
the test today so we can find out just
how satisfying the degasified pancake mix
really is now for this experiment today
I went down to the local grocery store
and picked up a box of this instant
pancake mix I also got a couple of eggs
some pancakes syrup as well as some milk
and some vegetable oil so to get started
I think we're just going to flip this
box over and follow the recipe on the
back to make a batch of classic pancakes
interesting side note these eggs are
from our chickens
♫ Instrumental Music ♫
look at those rich orange yolks
So here we are guys I just went ahead and
blended up all the ingredients as per
the instructions and this is what we've
got
a nice beautiful batch of pancake mix that
should make anywhere from 10 to
14 pancakes and I even brought up the
mixer just to pump a little extra air
into it as well you can see I've divided
the batter into two different batches
here one of them is going to get poured
on regularly to make a normal pancakes
the other one we're going to stick down
to the vacuum chamber and suck all the
bubbles out all right here we go vacuum
chamber versus pancake mix in 3 2 1
♫ Instrumental Music ♫
there are a lot of air bubbles in there.
It just keep's going
INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC
now this stuff is resilient, just won't give up it just keeps
going and going
I'm on like my 30th cycle
here and I'm still going going strong
but I think we're about to defeat it
it's on its last legs here, all those air
bubbles coming up out of the bottom
sucking them out slowly cycling the
process I think we're almost at the end
maybe another 15 or 20 cycles yeah there
it is there it is
this is where we get all the air out. It
looks kind of organic doesn't, it in fact
watch this if I turn off the vacuum pump
oh that's cool yeah looks like it's
alive we're going to leave this thing
running for a few more minutes and while
we're waiting let's go ahead and make a
regular batch of pancake so at least we
can get those on the menu
I can hot-hot-hot whoo that is pretty
hot maybe too hot I don't know let's
find out
here we go pancake number one now the
box says cook until the edges are dry
and then turn and cook until golden so
that's we're going to do following the
directions folks yeah I just look fairly
dry there go ahead and give it a flip
INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC
oh I burned it! Must been too hot we'll
need to feed that to the chickens it cooked
a little bit faster than I was expecting
go with pancake number two
Okay I'm not going to burn this one
Oh bullseye!
listen to that sizzle. Oh you see all the
bubbles rising here pretty sure we're
not going to have that with the vacuum
chamber version
oh very nice getting better it's crazy
the stuff is still going it's been
running for like I don't know 6-7
minutes and it's still bubbling what the
heck Oh fail that was bound to happen
whoo doggie all right our first batch of
Pancakes is done. Voila! Grant the chef
in training has just made pancakes and
it's what we've got this is a regular
batch and looking at them you can see
they looks just like regular pancakes
fluffy and golden-brown let's be honest
guys I really don't know how to cook
food in the kitchen it's not what I do
chemicals and experiments yes food not
too much bon appetite baby all right
so they passed the test I'm not a cook but
those definitely are pancakes now let's
try the version from the vacuum chamber
we've had this thing sitting in here for
about 10 minutes let's go ahead and
release the pressure there we go
and I'm going to make this transfer
really quick here because I think
there's a reaction taking place maybe
with the baking soda and the water to
produce the bubbles itself so the faster
we can get these things in the frying
pan the less bubbles will appear in our
solution
one seems to be a little flatter I'm
just looking at it from the side not
making any judgments yet just looking
for observations
whoa where'd that bubble come from
there's actually bubbles coming up in
in the pancake could it be from the
water turning into steam because after
ten minutes in the vacuum chamber there
theoretically shouldn't be any bubbles
right but that right there that's quite
a few bubbles I mean that there's
actually a lot of bubbles it's like a
bad break out of acne and see the
comments loading up trypophobia just
going to let that cook a little bit
longer that's really interesting pattern
man that looks so crazy actually don't
want to flip it over because that's
looking really cool it's like honeycomb
but scary now looks like there's little
holes you get from mango worms
I have to say that right there was a very
unexpected result huh yep pretty sure I
burned the heck out of the bottom there so
look at that the whole thing turned to
bubbles. Where'd those bubbles come from
guys? They didn't come from my batter I took all
the bubbles out of the batter
yep the bubbles are coming already look
at that what the heck if I don't flip it
over right away it starts bubbling up
like crazy
look at those things what the heck
that's crazy they're like English
crumpets or something how's it taste?
it tastes very dense it's not light and
fluffy like a pancake. It tastes uhm..
almost rubbery kinda tastes like chewing
on a hardened slime if you can imagine that
appetizing right? So these results were
completely unexpected first of all these
are the pancakes that we made normally
these are normal pancakes
pancake mix from the vacuum chamber on
the other hand makes something that
looks completely different how bizarre
look at these things these are
completely different and what's really
interesting is even though we sucked out
all the air bubbles
these ones are popped with bubbles look
at that looks like some kind of Beehive
honeycomb
it's crazy look at that. Y'know whats kind of
cool about this design though all those
little holes will catch more syrup so
you can really load these suckers up
Look at the way the syrup just soaks right down into those little bubbles taste
Taste test!
Firm, a little bit crunchy lots of syrup lots of flavor definitely not bad I
mean they're not pancakes but they're
not bad vacuum chambered pancakes
they're now a thing so guys today we set
out on a mission to find out what would
happen if you tried throwing pancake mix
in a vacuum chamber and sucking out all
the bubbles would you make pancakes
without bubbles the answers that came in
response to our experiments were very
very surprising we ended up with
pancakes with more bubbles both pancakes
look relatively the same on one side but
you flip them over and they look
absolutely different and in a weird way
I kind of feel like we invented some new
kind of organic species I mean it's
delicious but it's creepy the batter
that made these pancakes sat in a vacuum
chamber for over 10 minutes extracting
all the gas so why on earth did our
pancakes come out looking like this if
you have any theories on why bubble-free
pancake mix produce pancakes with
bubbles put your thoughts in the
comments below just for fun let's go
ahead and rip one of these things in
half and take a look at the
cross-section oh wow look at that it
almost looks like the spores of a
mushroom mushroom pancakes ha ha that's
crazy look at that it just like streaked
up it makes such an interesting looking
texture let's rip the top off and Kelly
the 12 layers at the bottom definitely
crust here at the bottom but it's still
very firm material all the way through
so there you have it guys using a vacuum
chamber and some pancake mix from the
grocery store we've managed to make
ourselves some of the most bizarre
looking pancakes I've ever seen in my
life
I mean those really are just really
odd-looking
and a big thanks to Remiel Kasim for being one of the many people requesting this experiment
you can go ahead and check your YouTube inbox
Remiel I'm sending you 25 bucks hey thanks for
joining me for this experiment I'll be
looking for you in next one talk to you
then
I keep spilling